how are you doing with your body at this
age because i don't i i'm a [ __ ]
machine look at this [ __ ]
you look good you actually don't look
good you actually do look good do you
work out i mean i work out but i work
out as a 60 year old man like when
people say like do you work out i do
those things that like jane fonda would
be like that's all you're doing like
it's it's i i work out like you do when
you see those articles as you scroll on
the web that are like after 60 how to
maintain your balance like make sure
that you can stand up without a railing
but the thing that they don't tell you
because getting older is humbling
and i think you you know this
no i know and
the other day this was the part i was
masturbating
and i had to get my reading glasses
yep
that's humiliating that when you can't
see
what you're and you're like why would i
masturbate to two people fixing a car
and then you're like oh wait hold on oh
yeah that's what i'm looking for that's
nice
that's bringing the joy but it's [ __ ]
humbling isn't it do you have a specific
type of pornography that you watch i
don't have brand loyalty
i say i'm interested most guys our age
do no no i understand i understand i
shift around you know i still consider
myself a you know a consumer who could
be captured that's that's what i'm
saying i want to make myself a more
viable consumer so you order whatever's
on the feed or you know just
robin that's right i here's the thing
why not let the curators at google or
whatever do their job let me trust the
algorithm to know what i'll like more
than
a brand loyalty howard you have to keep
an open mind as you get older have you
had this experience yet yeah uh where
you are are you say you just you make
the decision you want to masturbate to
porn
uh
and you
you know you give up in in the middle of
it like you're kind of like you know
what um you lose steam right have you
experienced that yet yeah howard you
know it's important horrible in
relationships to keep it fresh with
yourself
and that's why sometimes i'll
you know i'll i'll come up with a
special outfit or some music that i know
i like
you know i know and uh really you got to
set the scene because here's the thing
howard
you can't take yourself
for granted
you really have to demonstrate yourself
because
otherwise
you know you have to value yourself in
that way
you